中大胆周报
欢迎收看中大胆周报
中大胆周报公开版269集
大家看到这一集的时候
一定很想赶快问中大胆
没有想到真的回测到
4万3000点以下了
想都没有想到
而且因为星期五的时候
我们历经到
台股史上最大的单日迭点
真的是说来就来
但是说来就来的话
中大胆倒是一点都不担心
也不紧张
他要教大家的
就是接下来这个礼拜
一个对的策略跟方向
其实43,000我不是没想到
我认为会有想到
所以我们为什么之前在公开版本
有跟大家提到过
稳健的投资人
你设在43,000
那果然有见到43,000
如果我也很乐观
我上礼拜
大家很多人都去建议
要买台积电法收会的相关概念股
我们上礼拜在我们隐藏版当中
买穿餐股
我现在看到有一些
大家市场上就提到
要把电子股的钱移到穿餐股
坦白讲
那个应该是上礼拜
你应该就在开始做防御型的
我上礼拜就有跟大家提到过
台积电的法收会很看好
问题呢
陈嘉任为什么会递减
这表示一定是有人看哪
比较保守
所以我们上礼拜才提到过
萬一台積電法說我沒那麼好的話
那這個盤可能就會比較弱
那果然是不出我所料
那我們來看一下這一波的大環指數
已經跌破上升趨勢線
那勢必要拉長整理的時間
投信呢近期有連續買超
所以呢換句話說至少這個信心
我覺得你開以為實在
我到現在我覺得還是逢低可以去買
像禮拜五大跌的時候我就去做布局
因为大事上我也不知道
可能我买我发现头信也买
所以表示我们的想法是一致
因为如果未来5万点
我还特别想象未来会5万点
但是呢这波我很少会跟你讲会5万点
为什么呢
因为呢量不增加本来就不容易过
而且呢在我们第265集我就提到过
5万点的下缘是48,500
我们之前提到过
每一次的万点都有3%的测试
那48,500
如果连碰都不碰
怎么会有5万点
我想之前你在听公开拍
我已经跟各位提到过
那现在呢
48,500没有碰到
表示5万点
它压力还存在的
那4万5呢
下源43650
之前是因为有支撑
那看起来这一波
有破43650
表示什么
短线要从5万点的关卡
下一道4万5
那虽然呢
礼拜五大跌
来到42671
也破季限
但我觉得如果你长期有在听我的盘式的话
原则上我都建议你在44,500点
即使现在大轨
其实相对领套的空间也不是很大
那我个人认为说短线来讲的话
43,650到46,350这边
如果达到的话
应该先做未来反弹
有来到这位置的话
你要先做解码
最主要是45,000的上下
所谓的上趴
大概就是这个位置
所以这个附近会持续在做一个测试整理动作
那我认为说量能递减45,000这个大观
重新再整理再出发会比较好一点
那对于大凡的走势来讲
我的看法依然不变
我不会去改变
我相信现在很多人都跟你讲
哎呦四万点会不会守得住
那想说奇怪
不到半个月前大家看五万点
怎么现在马上看四万点
我还是坚守我的看法
长线支撑43,000已经来到了你在这位置就如我事前所提的开始做一个布局动作这一波我们有分积极跟稳健型的
因为积极型你本来就是操作灵活
那稳健型就是你本来就是等待
有适当的大跌的买点
那现在呢如果你是积极型的
44500点以下
我坦白讲都可以去做建议做布局
因为投信成本差不多就那边
你套投信也套
那投信呢早晚會幫你繼續做解套
那但是最重要的是你的持股時間不能太短
那48218當做的大黑黑黑
原本預估要花兩到三週的時間消耗
因為量能不出大概會以盤代碟
將會延緩整理將近五週的時間
我講以盤代碟是
雖然你說禮拜五是大碟也是沒錯
但是如果就整個大盤大格局來講的話
大约上应该会在43000点附近
会尽量以盘来带碟
那当然要观察下个礼拜台积电法说
后续的法能效应
那我个人认为说
长线的支撑还是在前8周的
红K地点43000点附近
有拉回到这里
你可以把持股比重拉高到8到9成
那坦白上礼拜五已经有来到这位置
你现在可以开始做布局动作
如果你是稳健型的
或者说你之前是积极跟稳健
你都有搭配的话
你这个位置我就建议
逢低影就开始做买件动作
我就特别强调
我不会说看涨的时候跟你说涨
看跌的时候给你看保守
因为这样子
你永远都是在做追高杀低
不是吗
你现在一定是杀低
但是呢
我们要发现
这一波的拉回4万5测试是失败
但是呢
我现在发现
目前市场上在寻找一条长期的上升趋势线
像我们的周K线
我上礼拜还跟各位提到过
周上涨2000点的空间已经越来越小
我上禮拜才
难做
已经跟各位提到过了
表示我心中已经早就已经有这个
就已经有这个想法了
那我涂上我们可以发现
坦白讲最好的买点就是那个
我涂上长期换到长期的上升区世界
这个位置大概落到三万八三万七
但真的会来到这位置吗
我个人我不会卡在看到那位置
因为我上次提到过
大盘如果今年的企业获利
成长四成左右
大概落到多少点
4万零500到4万一
但是呢股票本来就是会领先
企业获利的部分
所以我认为4万三
我不会就往下去做
修正
但是你会说
你看到42671
你不一定要买到最低点
大概就4万三以下
我觉得你就是可以做布局动作
现在出场上就在找一条我涂上画的这条
蓝色上线巨色
你会发现
大家就会觉得
好像那一条线
就是狗跟主人那条
因为那个之前的主人是那条黄色
但是现在回到那个位置我个人认为不容易
我自己目前抓应该会落在4万到4万3附近
这个附近但真实的位置在哪里
我不知道
但是那个位置我觉得
这个位置4万3以下
我觉得你还是可以买
反正4万3附近我就建议买
但是你不要太一口气都买
因为现在毕竟还有一些筹码要洗
你就是挑好股票
然后呢
好的对象
你就做买进
那台股出现较大拉回
你现阶段该怎么办呢
我们大概把
大家的想法
在这边提供给大家
做一个参考
第一个
你尽量不要做融资
你不是用融资的
你就等待反弹机会
你相信我
因为呢
我以前
被那个券商经济单位的主管
找去帮忙的
通常都是大跌的时候
大涨的时候
都不會找我
各個都是股神每樣隨便買都是厲害都不會找我們投顧的在大碟的時候會希望投顧來幫忙找一些好標的坦白講通常大跌的時候那標定放進去給客戶買
通常大概兩個月或三個月之後
慢慢就看到開花結果
但是這些一般的客戶
不會去用融資買
所以呢
如果你不是用融資的
你這段時間就忍耐一下
第二個
電子持股比重要下降
這個部分就是我們上禮拜
為什麼會在我們引商買
去建议买传商股
那虽然传商股也是有一些亏损
但是比电子股来讲的话
这个简直是小乌乌见大乌了
那我个人认为说电子股比重下降
最主要是那个叫做弹性
就做防疫型的
再来就是跌时种植
当全面性下跌就表示什么
表示一定有公式凑杀嘛
合理吧
过去的台积电
过去的股王 信华
也是陪着大家去走过这个股灾
那为什么这些到最后面
都能够走得很强
那表示什么
现在大跌当中
你就要冷静思考
要找哪些股票
还是一样
那五个字
定静 安律的
你一定要让你先
心要定下来
那你能够心定下来
就是因为你没有农资
你就当作是账上
有沒有帳面短暫的這個所謂的虧損
那好公司早晚會回來
除非台灣未來就是這個科技實力不強
那台灣科技實力不強
我想全世界也差不多了
再來就是你
但是這個有兩個地方要注意
你需要觀察一段時間
包括籌碼穩定不穩定
因為呢通常主力他會觀察
進去一段這個籌碼穩定度是如何
然后再决定下一次的操作重点是哪个列股租群
第二个呢
你短线如果或许短道
但重点是什么
未来能不能反弹创新高
例如台积电
大家都知道台积电来到季线
坦白讲是一个很好机会
像礼拜五我也去买台积电
但我不会是买很多
我就开始用零股零股去买进
反正呢
你知道台积电未来
价钱会有更高
3000块
或更高的价钱
那你这时候买
你只是什么
用更低的成本买进
所以我想這個部分
重點就是你買了之後
短套沒關係
未來會有創新高的機會
那才最重要
然後呢
第四個穩健的
你可以逐步做進場
機器型的你可以短套
沒關係等攤平機會
再來動態調整
你要維持一定的現金比
你說其實我們也會去操作什麼
有一些部分的虧損
然後幹嘛
虧損完之後
你再買一些比較好的公司
坦白講啦
偷偷跟各位交一个方式
之前我们在我们的公开版也教大家
好的公司最便宜的时候就是这时候买
坦白讲好公司你就这时候才有用比较低的成本买
否则平常台积人哪有那么好的价格可以买
所以你这时候有烂公司的
你可以记得你可以砍掉
因为大家很清楚
如果大跌的时候你一定要买最好的公司
因为上涨的时候不一定烂公司一定会跑前面
一定是好公司要跑到前面
你才有信心嘛
这部分也给另外给三点给大家做参考
就是你当价持股亏损卖出
你同时要布局一些机油股
这样子你在前面先亏
但是你买一些机油股
未来他赚的时候
刚好你补你的亏损的部分
你千万不要就是亏损的不卖
然后呢你也好公司跌的时候你不买
你一定要两手策略
同时做进
坦白讲这时候就叫泰路流墙
是
再来呢
高于台积电股价的公司
我建议你把它降低比重
因为最主要成交量考量因为成交量不高你在这边买那种3000块、4000块、5块五千块坦白讲我个人是认为这个市场上的法人应该比较没兴趣如果比台积电还贵
那我就买台积电
所以合理嘛
除非是成交量回到1.5兆
可能市场上有市区
那这些超高价股才有动人
不则现阶段没有动人
那我就买台积电就好
为什么要买到这些更高价钱
那你还是留一些现金
等待摊平点
最主要是GEO公司
那台股出现较大拉回时
现阶段该怎么办的
积极心态
刚才是稳健的
比较基本的心态
第一
融资使用
你先降低你的比重或去除
因为融资是有利息的
你除了账面的价差亏损
还有所谓的融资利息
你要先降低你这部分
有压力的部分
第二个呢
停损观念很重要
坎壁保命概念非常重要
简单讲如果你被毒蛇咬
你要留命还是留那手臂
一定先砍手臂或砍脚
因为你留得清山寨
不怕没机会
最重要的是
你如果都没有适当的做停损
那相对的你到时候可能就是
整个人都赔下去
那高乖利的获利要先出
长多高乖利你先不碰
然后你还去检查你的手中的持股
如果营收获利成长
你就不用担心
为什么
未来如果要市场上再买回来
不是挑營收成长的
获利成长的
然后是不是有高股息殖利率
那股息殖利率有保护的话
股价跌刚好成本更低
那最重要是
你持股要去检视
你的强弱度是如何
我想透过这样的部分
来跟大家做说明
那持股怎么检视呢
强弱度呢
我觉得至少在多方当中
有两个
至少要一个
第一个是
能否在季线上
因为坦白说
目前大盘也在季线上
如果能在月线上
那更好
所以我想这个是
第一个部分
第二个呢
能不能守住近月的前波低点位置
坦白讲这个表示什么
至少是跌底高
至少这表示它是上升的趋势的部分
所以如果是这样的话
我简单找一个例子来做说明
在6月7号第257集
我们讲的这叫福茂科
当时的价格刚好就是夜盘
跌四五千点
刚好成本就那位置
那还原全息之后
这波曾经大涨
没多久
才一个礼拜前左右
大概有赚到40%左右
那你会发现
第一个
然而不我守在季线上
你会发现
确实现在守在季线日上左右
第二个呢
然不我守处前波的低点位置
有比守前波低点
至少到目前
如果像这样的股票
你可以去续报
但如果是刚好跟它相反
破季线
然后呢
底底低
那这样子
你就可以
这个部分就未来要先考量做解码的动作
我想这是有关这个部分
至于呢
因为时间有限
关于未来大盘的走势
我跟各位讲
我会在隐藏盘当中
再跟各位做进一步的说明
因为这大盘不会马上V转的
要一段时间做一个整理
好
有时候机会来到的时候
但是您是把它当作机会
还是当成危机
可能就跟您的持股策略
有很大的关系
这一波大盘果然来到中大胆
觉得是稳健的人
也可以拉高持股的地方
但也因为这样
上面的套劳压力是比较大的
也不要期待一下子就会V转
在选股逻辑上太弱流强
那有很多人会想要知道
哇那现阶段
中大胆会想要选的股票是什么呢
上个礼拜选的是传产
非常之抗跌
那这个礼拜呢
好有些去知道进一步的策略
跟选股逻辑的朋友
也欢迎订阅我们的VIP
我会把订阅的连结
放在留言的第一则
那我们就VIP再来聊啰
优优独播剧场——YoYo Television Series Exclusive